je ne crois pas que on soit alcoolique
en France il y a des alcooliques qui
vivent très vieux il y a il y a des
presque des centenaires tandis que la
drogue ça vous tue tout ça vous escin
fatalement ça vous tue il y a plus
d'homme à la maison on boit du café mais
si sorti de la maison le premier bistroc
qu'il y a je commence au blanc quoi
alors mon travail 7 h bistrons alors
c'est du blanc du blanc et pas des
petits des ballons oui le vin c'est
vraiment pas de l'alcool c'est une
nourriture si on veut le vin non c'est
pas de l'alcool
c'est ça fait du bien le vain vous allez
chez les gens faire du travail bon la
première chose qu'on vous dit voulez
boire un coup ça c'est la France quoi
une bonne bouteille mais il y a toujours
une bonne bouteille sur la table ça
c'est
évident c'est pas pour ça qu'on est
alcoolique un petit
coup